when I first uh heard about the rehab
center I was extremely skeptical it
always struck me as strange why would
the most conservative country in the
world be running a Progressive Rehab
program for extremists like that doesn't
make sense to me what I realized
spending so much time there is number
one the idea that all these men are hard
and ideological uh you know soldiers is
not true
two there is a kind of you know
bandwidth of like yeah you have you have
the leadership who definitely are a lot
harder to kind of get on board with this
whole rehabilitation
but the foot soldiers some of the people
that you see in the film who aren't in
that leadership aren't in that kind of
uh upper respiratory it's a little bit
different
I knew that this film was going to get
attacked I didn't think it was going to
be from the left though I was pretty
sure it was going to be from the right
so if you can't even watch a two-hour
film before chiming in if that's too
much energy for you to do then you are
not a journalist
you are an activist that writes
you are not a documentarian
you're an activist with a camera if
there's something in the film that is
factually inaccurate and we [ __ ] up
yes I will when you do something wrong
you should apologize but for me
apologize apologizing or apologies are
not performative I'm not [ __ ]
apologizing for this [ __ ] because
there's nothing wrong with this film
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is like probably like no one
we've had on the show before she's a
documentary filmmaker who's made a movie
about the rehabilitation of some
Guantanamo prisoners in Saudi Arabia
that no one for some reason wants to
show makes Maca welcome to trigonometry
yeah it's maker by the way smaker yeah
it's okay I [ __ ] up already there
don't say your terrorist bodies on me
um it's great to have you on the show
makes maker I apologize for that I
should have asked
um before we get into the conversation
about your brilla movable Francis and I
both watched it last night and really
enjoyed it and it's I can't for the life
of me understand why people don't want
to show it anyway we'll get into all
that but before we do who are you how
are you where you are what has been the
journey through life that leads you to
be sitting here talking to us oh that's
not a mouthful
tell me your life story and your purpose
um yeah
okay so I'll do my best uh I am a
documentary filmmaker but I wasn't
always a documentary filmmaker uh for a
long time ago
um in a in a former life I was a
firefighter and I loved it and thought I
was B1 and then 9 11 happened
and uh my whole kind of world shifted
and
um
my dad always said that there's pretty
much only three types of people in the
world those when you hit them they hit
you right back those when you hit them
they run away and those when you hit
them they ask why'd you hit me
and I've always kind of been in that
third Camp so after 9 11 that was a
question
why'd you hit me and I started to kind
of do research and read books about
Islam and the in the history of the
Middle East and just watch the news
ferociously
and I began to see that what I would see
in the news was directly contradicting
what I was reading about and I realized
after a while that both those sources of
information was through someone else's
filter
so I figured the only way to remove that
filter
was to like go and get the information
firsthand so about six months after 9 11
I traveled to Afghanistan to try to find
those answers for myself
and was immediately humbled by my own
ignorance in the world I don't do you
remember what you were like when you
were in your early 20s yes yes
I said yeah yeah uh you have this very
self-assured view of the world and uh
that all kind of came crumbling down
when I went to Afghanistan and that kind
of set me on a journey to try to educate
myself so I went back to the States it
was a firefighter for a little bit
longer and then
um shortly after moved the Middle East
moved to Yemen lived there for almost
five years studied Arabic and Islamic
culture and while I was there I taught
yemeni men how to fight fire and then
lived in Qatar for a year traveled all
around the Middle East I think to every
country except for Syria and Kuwait and
um through those experiences decided
that I wanted to change careers from
firefighting to filmmaking because I was
seeing the stories that I was seeing and
experiencing
I didn't see represented anywhere in
Main Street Media
so I went back to the US went to
Stanford and got an MFA and documentary
filmmaking and made a film that won a
student Academy Award and then this is
my next project that just premiered at
Sundance and yeah that is a cliff note
version I could possibly Cliff notice
that's not a word we're gonna make it up
version I can possibly give you about
who I am and why I'm here well it's a
fascinating lifestyle first of all you
mentioned uh coming to Afghanistan with
a self-assured but ignorant world view
yeah what did you learn there
um well I think for me the things that I
had gotten from our media was you know
they hate us because our freedom you'll
go to go over there and these people are
going to hate you and try to kill you or
kidnap you and the opposite was true so
for example uh I basically hitched High
across Afghanistan and this family in
one of these Villages took me in
and clothed me fed me uh I didn't speak
pashtune they didn't speak English but I
have amazing charades and Pictionary
skills so we communicated through that
that line
um and I was staying with them for a
little bit and one day we went out and
to the local market it was a very small
village and it was with the grandfather
in the grand side of the house
and we're walking through and there's
another guy in the market who started
just shouting the top of his lungs at me
and waving his fist in the air I didn't
know what he was saying but I can pretty
much take his mating from his gestures
and his uh his voice that he you know
didn't want me there and was very angry
because my country was bombing his
country at that particular time
uh the grandfather that I was staying
with went up to the guy picked him up by
the Scruff of the neck yelled at him put
him down and the guy walked over and
said sorry in postun and welcome to
Afghanistan in English
now
these guys probably know each other for
decades it's a small village and yet
this person welcomed me into his home uh
defended me against someone else in the
village she was angry that I was there
and it just went against everything that
I had been taught about these people
from the media and so I just realized
that
um my understanding of the world was
very limited
does that make sense a nice complete
sense so what inspired you to make the
film
uh yeah I mean I think it's a it's a
plethora of things
um tell everybody what it's called as
well so they can so the original title
was Jihad rehab and it got changed to
the unredacted so it's now the
unredacted and
um yeah it's it's a kind of a plethora
of things it's that question I told you
before why they hit us try to understand
the why of it but also after Afghanistan
I did a lot of traveling I had a lot of
to places that usually people don't
travel to like Somalia Afghanistan Iraq
Colombia and I met a lot of people who I
think a lot of us
think we know about and have strong
opinions of but actually don't have a
lot of one-on-one conversations with
meaning we talk about these people but
we rarely talk with them so for example
I interviewed pirates in Somalia
Warlords in Afghanistan uh rebels in
Colombia and
um yeah I just kind of set me on a
trajectory to kind of there's this quote
from Dostoevsky where I just it used to
be in the film but I took it out and he
says um
the easiest thing in the world is to
denounce the evildoer the most difficult
thing in the world is to try to
understand him and that's what the film
is essentially trying to do to try to
understand these men on a human level if
that makes sense that makes complete
sense and what you do so beautifully in
the film is because we all have these
stereotypes of Islamic fundamentalist
jihadists whatever you want to call them
but you actually get to understand them
you humanize you humanize them
beautifully and you end up sympathizing
with them and you get a level of
understanding like I the thing that
struck me about the film is for many of
these particularly very young boys one
of them was 16 it's a search for
belonging yeah yeah I mean I think
there's a at least for me anyway I
interviewed over 150 of these guys and
um after a while I began to see a
pattern and as I was making this film it
reminded me of a story my dad told me
about starfish of all things and he said
that there was a fishing Village in
Northern California that had a problem
with invasive starfish one day the
fishermen decided to get together just
kill all the starfish once and for all
so they collect them up cut them into
three four five pieces thinking the
starfish were dead they threw the pieces
back into the ocean not knowing that
starfish regenerate so there's one
before now there's five
the starfish population exploded and
just devastated the local fishing
economy the moral of the story being
when you try to fix a problem you do not
understand you usually make it worse day
after 9 11 most experts put the number
of al-Qaeda members around 400. just
before the Pandemic those same experts
put the number around a hundred thousand
including affiliate groups so basically
the US has been starfishing the [ __ ] of
Middle East for the last two decades
um and partly because we don't
understand
don't understand these men we don't
understand their motivation and I think
when you use simplistic rhetoric and you
kind of go off that your decisions are
flawed so for example in the film like I
talked about there's
it's it's a film about four guys or four
guys some about a group of men who spent
15 years in Guantanamo and then they're
sent to Saudi Arabia to the world's
first rehabilitation center for
terrorists and they're they and they're
there for about a year year and a half
in the film we follow them for three
years year and a half in the rehab
center and then a year and a half when
they get out and they try to find jobs
get married have kids start a family and
for me the really interesting thing
about making this film is seeing a lot
of kind of commonalities between these
men and men that I know in my own life
and seeing that there's a way more in
common that we have different that yeah
it does make sense as well I think
you're about to ask but uh what I really
like I actually would disagree with
Francis to some extent because while I
sympathize sympathize with some of them
yeah I also think you do a very good job
of not doing this sort of like oh
they're all just like us and they're all
perfect little precious little flowers
because you talk to a guy who's to make
bombs for living yeah right and you talk
to a guy who's clearly clearly what was
the guy's name the one that I said
earlier was really scary oh Abu got him
right I mean that dude is [ __ ]
terrifying because he clearly is very
committed to Jihad has absolutely no no
intention of reforming himself or
anything like that and you show that in
the movie so you're not sort of going
over there going oh I've just realized
everyone is sweet and perfect you tried
to give a rounded picture that some of
the people who ended up uh going through
by the way and you emphasize this I
think it's very important to say you
know I'm someone who's just written a
book called an immigrant's love letter
to the West I think
uh in my experience uh the West is a
Force for good generally speaking uh
doesn't mean we don't make mistakes of
course yeah but
in my lifetime the one time the first
time I looked at the United States and I
went you guys aren't living up to the
own your own standards that you preach
was Guantanamo Bay yeah right because
okay 911 was an awful atrocity it was an
awful atrocity but it doesn't entitle
you to suspend habeas corpus it doesn't
entitle you to just imprison people 15
years without charge Etc and this is
what these guys went through and some of
them probably were completely innocent
or close to completely innocent others
were hardened terrorists and you show
both of those yeah I think that the
thing about this particular film is
there have been quite a lot of people
who've gone to Afghanistan who had
absolutely nothing to do with any
terrorist group
um and it was literally a wrong place
wrong time and there's been quite a few
films and and and and sort of stories
and articles set on that but what I
wanted to do with this film is men who
from their own mouth talk about being
involved these groups and in a plethora
of different ways and a plethora of
different levels so for example you have
someone like Ali who went to an Al-Qaeda
training camp and was there for two
three weeks
and then 9 11 happened they got picked
up and sent to guantano when he was 16
and didn't get out until he was almost
32. and then you have someone like
Khalid who you know was one of the lead
bomb makers and bomb instructors for Al
Qaeda and so there's a huge like
differences in level of culpability and
level of involvement and it like talks
about or explores some of the Nuance of
that for example the word sex offender
you say that's a very charged word but a
sex offender can qualify someone as in
the United States if you're 18 years old
and you sleep to us with a 16 year old
it could also describe someone like
Harvey Weinstein and those things are
very far apart and so when you're
watching the movie Not only does it kind
of dive into like the different
motivations but the different levels of
involvement and how using a word like
terrorists to describe all these men is
actually really kind of dumbing down the
conversation because it's way more
complex and nuanced than that yeah and
you said that we don't understand
and you've said it a couple of times
what don't we understand make what are
the things that people need to learn and
need to understand who are not aware of
this well I can't talk for the UK but I
think in the states the narrative has
been quite simplistic for example it's
all because of the religious or they
hate us because of Freedom it's very
like simplistic rhetoric when when you
look at the film like I said I
interviewed 150 of these guys and the
reason why there's four characters in
the film is because each after I
interviewed so many of them I started to
see a pattern and they would fall into
one of four motivations about why they
got into these groups
um there was exceptions of course as
there always is but but it would be one
of these four things and that's why
there's four characters because each one
of the subjects of the film represent a
different motivation
the one that I think most Americans at
least are familiar with is the cause so
that's abuganum right he thinks it's a
religious duty to go and defend his
fellow Muslims he got into this because
of Bosnia he was living in Yemen about
to go to college he saw the Bosnian War
happening and thought that you know no
one's there helping my fellow Muslims
it's my duty my religious treat to go do
that
but the other three have absolutely
nothing to do with religion and I think
this is where the dialogue kind of stops
in the at least the United States
uh the second motivation is economic
necessity that's not her right so he's
like I need a job I need money this is a
career and it became a career for him
then you have the third motivation is
peer pressure that's Ali his older
brother was in this he said hey come to
the training camp I'm a trainer here and
he came over and
decided to uh to to do a two-week credit
training three-week training course I
want to say before 9 11 happened and
then the last one is more age dependent
more for the younger guys and that sense
of adventure and that's Muhammad right
he says you know I was 19. I was bored I
didn't want to go to school I didn't
want to work this guy offered me a free
ticket to Afghanistan and shoot Rockets
so why not
um and the
they all were also searching for a sense
of belonging and sense of purpose and
that was also a commonality as well
but what I found interesting after
talking to a lot of these people is
have you ever heard of a book called
tribe by Sebastian younger
no no he did a film called Restrepo
where he was embedded with a bunch of
Marines during the Afghan war and it was
a one of the bloodiest outposts in in
the military out there for the US
Military
and reading them doing a lot of research
for the for the film I read a lot of
books about vets and Military and things
like that and I began to like both read
and from friends of mine who were in the
military I see a lot of commonalities
between two so for example when you're
talking about those four causes
I know a lot of men who joined the
military right after 9 11 the Cause
right
people like me who don't have like come
from loads of money and university in
the United States is quite expensive go
join the military to help pay for school
right economic necessity
um a lot of friends of mine come from
military families dad uncles Brothers
all in the military peer pressure
and a lot of people who and they even
advertise this in a lot of the the
adverts for the military is it's an
adventure goes through the world travel
the world and if you don't have
disposable income that's a good way to
do it and so what I realized it wasn't
about Good and Evil it's about time and
Circumstance and what time and
Circumstance do you live in that led you
to a certain decision-making process
I I hear you I I I I quibble with the
idea of it there not being good and evil
to that extent because I think there is
a difference the motivations may be
similar but there's a difference between
hijacking a civilian plane and flying it
into buildings yeah I'm not saying
that's similar I'm just saying the
motivations to go into this are quite
yeah but I think the reason people would
make the distinction between good and
evil is if you go and join your
country's military because for the same
with the same motivation the military
will do lots of bad things but most of
them will be by accident they're not
going to deliberately Target civilians
whereas with the terrorism issue I think
that's where a lot of people's
instinctive like oh this is just pure
evil thing comes in which is you've got
people you know and it's interesting
it's quite shocking watching watching
the movie where you hear these guys
talking about
watching 911 happen yeah and one of them
at the beginning of the movie goes oh
it's just a building build a new one
yeah because these people don't even
at that point really think about what it
is that's happened and for some of them
it was only later when they saw it and
they saw people jumping out when they
were confronted with the true horror of
it I think that's where you know for me
at least personally the the light I I
don't think I want to blow that line for
me you know there's a difference between
9 11 and joining the US military you
know yeah
911 and joining the US military but
um I would say that like when you're
talking about body count
you have over 3 000 people died on 9 11.
the warranty has gone on for two decades
and 100 thousands of people have died
so
I think the line that you're drawing and
the line that I would say that I'm
drawing as well is the film is not
saying that these men are right you're
not saying they're wrong it's not trying
to sympathize with us this one I want to
be clear on there's a difference between
sympathy and empathy and empathy is just
for trying to understand them
and I think a lot of times in the US
people conflate that for example like I
think that just the act of trying to
understand someone's point of view that
you don't agree with which I love doing
uh doesn't mean that you actually
sympathize with that person just trying
to understand where they're coming from
and so I would say that the the film
walks this line between trying to
understand them but not quite
sympathizing with them and to your point
I think that it's okay to draw lines of
commonality to help you understand
something but you're not necessarily
Drawing the Line saying they're
identical they're similar they're the
same right um clearly when you
intentionally Target civilians right
that's very different than when you're
you know
bombing like military targets so I had
this long conversation with Khalid and
for him the reason why I became a bomb
maker is because he had a degree in
electrical engineering and so the way he
describe it to me is that when they do
an intake interview in Al Qaeda Alpha
Rook uh based on your level of Education
your level of intelligence uh your
background you go into one of three
categories in terms of you're either not
you're a planner you're an operator or
you're an executioner in terms of like
you're the one they strapped the bomb to
um so clearly College was quite
intelligent and smart so he wasn't that
wasn't his his job but yeah he did train
people how to make bombs for sure so
there's a very clear structure and the
most malleable the most vulnerable would
be the ones who
do the deed as it were yeah yeah I would
say that like when I was talking to
Colin and some of the other guys during
that intake interview if you were seen
as having like a lower uh intelligence
level or not as much education than they
would put you on those lower levels to
be the ones that would you would have
either have the bomb or or a lot of
these guys volunteered for it as well so
according to college there was like a
list of 200 people I think he mentions
it in the film yeah yeah so it and and
it's not because they it's easier to
manipulate that type of person and get
them to do what you want or is it just
because they see these people as load
skilled and therefore Expendable well I
don't want to put words in people's
mouths because I've actually not like
interviewed any any of those people but
I would I would say that it seemed to
from the description that I've gotten
from a lot of these guys that was
actually very organized in that aspect
so if you came in for example and you
had
um a level of English yep right you
could then use you in the PRD
so for example Isis had some pretty good
videos in terms of the production
quality in terms of like compared to
earlier versions of it there's actually
a book
um that is uh I forget the name of it
but one of the chapter is um
cinematography cinematography uh for
terrorists and basically it talks about
some of the tropes they use in order to
um give a certain emotional resonance
with you young young men so this is
actually quite
um well organized and and uh quite
thorough organization yeah and the thing
that was interesting about the film is
you the first part of it where you were
looking at the rehab facility let's just
call it that and everything that was
happened that was happening there
it felt very positive but then when they
reintegrated into society you saw that
for the vast majority of these men it
was impossible to reintegrate
uh I think that had more to do with the
timing of when they graduated right so
before when the the center was run by
Muhammad bin knife and this was his pet
project right he uh literally invented
these centers and
um Muhammad but not just to clarify for
the audience and the listeners was sorry
he was a previous uh Crown Prince he was
going to be king of Saudi Arabia when
the current King died and then he got
replaced by no no so he so the current
King was alive and the and it's still
alive uh but Muhammad knife was the
Crown Prince which means second it's
like their vice president the second
command yeah right um and so when when
the current King died he was supposed to
take over that's what I mean yeah yeah
but instead of that he got replaced yes
by Mohamed bin Salman exactly
um and so
typically like when you have a change of
leadership you also have a change of
priorities so for example in the U.S you
had Obama signing the Paris Accord and
he was like we're all about the
environment Trump comes in we're like
we're not doing that anymore
um similar in Saudi Arabia where you had
Muhammad knife this was his pet project
he literally met almost every graduate
who like left the center he went to some
of their weddings he was very involved
in this process where the new Crown
Prince it just wasn't on the top
priority for him so these guys typically
would have gotten jobs and things like
this but because of the transition and
power they kind of fell through the
cracks and were left to their own
devices unfortunately yeah and one of
the fascinating things about seeing
because you spent three years with these
guys right yeah inside this facility and
this facility is called the Care
Rehabilitation Center yeah it's called
uh what is the change of the name
recently but it was called the Bahama
knife Care Counseling and Care Center
yeah or the rehab center for and what
was incredible is you're watching these
guys who've spent some of them 15 years
in Guantanamo they've clearly been
tortured they've been through horrific
ordeals in there and here they are these
are so according to our world Western
world view these are evil terrorists and
they've got like a swimming pool sauna
daily classes on how to how to think
they're teaching them critical thinking
they're teaching them social skills
they're teaching them I I like I found
it quite funny the scene where he's
teaching them how to deal with women
yeah he's like you must compliment the
smell of the meal
what you have to understand you're not
integrating them into Western Society
they've got their own standards yeah I
did take a few notes it was like a good
point good point good point yes I'm
going to incorporate but they're great
scenes because you see the world these
guys are coming from and the world that
they're going back into yeah hopefully
right and that was eye-opening as well
because you're seeing people who are the
evilest of the evil the the vilest of
the while the vile being treated
humanely and some of them at least are
actually benefiting from the process and
a lot of them you know they claim to
have an 85 success rate so it is
possible because we had a a guy called
em and Dean on the show who's a former
Al-Qaeda double agent and he said like
you can't really rehabilitate terrorists
like it's very very difficult but
clearly this program was having good
success it wasn't universally successful
but it was having good success and it
was fascinating to see these people
being treated well did were you did you
find that quite like a shock or would it
was that natural dude like how did you
find that
um so when I first uh heard about the
rehab center it was extremely skeptical
right uh for three reasons number one it
always struck me as strange why were the
most conservative country in the world
be running a Progressive Rehab program
for extremists like that doesn't make
sense to me two again Saudi Arabia is
not known for its human rights record
[Laughter]
well you know uh three I think that like
for me a lot of the things that I've
seen from the Saudi government
especially in the Press I kind of take
with a grain of salt
um and so I before I went to the rehab
center I reached out to all the
journalists that I could that had been
there before and asked about their
experience and they kind of all said the
same thing they're going to take you
give you like an hour PowerPoint do a
dog and pony show they'll give you two
hours their tops but they're pretty much
not gonna really learn anything new that
we haven't covered
um and when I told him I wanted to do a
documentary there they all like laughed
at me over the phone
um but what you have to understand is
like
the origin story of the center is quite
interesting and once you know that then
it makes sense why the Saudis are doing
this but when I first got there I was
extremely skeptical about this place
because again what the idea that I had
is these were like really hardened
criminals right and they were super into
the ideology and there's no way doing
art therapy and you know teaching them
how to you know balance a checkbook is
going to somehow reverse that but what I
realized spending so much time there is
number one the idea that all these men
are hard and ideological uh you know
soldiers is not true
two there is a kind of you know
bandwidth of like yeah you have you have
the leadership who definitely what the
guy was talking about before are a lot
harder to kind of get on board to this
whole Rehabilitation
foot soldiers some of the people that
you see in the film who aren't in that
leadership aren't in that kind of uh
upper sorry it's a little bit different
um so for example you were talking about
classes like finding a wife right
so for guys that the center calls the
normal terrorists the ones that they
catch going back and forth between Syria
and
um Iraq and Saudi Arabia to join Isis or
Al-Qaeda their program is only three to
four months long
the guys that are going from Guantanamo
though their program is a year long the
reason is twofold number one they're way
more radicalized because if we've just
taken you for 15 years and tortured you
and separated you from your family
without any like you know court case not
going to be the happiest camper in the
world and so a lot of the instructors at
the center say when these guys arrive
from Guantanamo the first thing they
want is Revenge they want to kill the
first American they see
um so that's one the second reason is
why it's so long compared to the other
one is because again you have someone
like Ali who when he went in when he was
16.
got out when he was almost 32. these are
some of the most formative years the
young man's life right so the life
skills that one picks up during that
time they did not get for example how to
balance a budget like how to find a way
but no if if your motivation is economic
necessity and you don't have funding
actually learning how to do a budget is
going to help that like and that's what
I mean in terms of you need to
understand the motivations in order to
understand how to deter those things
yeah and the World by the way has
changed a lot in the last 60 years so
you've kind of been deprived of like the
internet didn't really exist in the same
yeah these guys did literally didn't
know what Google was right had no idea
what Google was that's an impressive
scene in in a weird way yeah yeah but it
it's just like you well a lot of people
think Robin Tana would think of prison
it's not prisons because in prison you
can have your family can visit you you
can watch the UTV and you can learn
about what's going on in the world when
these during the Bush Administration
according to you know most people I've
talked to they weren't really allowed to
have any contact with the outside world
including TV
and it wasn't until Obama came in they
were allowed to have TV and things like
this and what was really interesting is
most of the main characters in the film
the exception of Khalid didn't speak
English before they went to Guantanamo
they learned English in Guantanamo and
one of my favorite scenes that we had to
take out
um was when Ali tells the story of how
he learned English
so he was quite Young when he went to
Guantanamo 16 and when Obama came in
they allowed him to have TVs and he told
me that one of the guards kind of took
pity on him because he was so young and
he said you know you're a young kid you
should be playing video games
so I really don't know what video games
to ask for what video game should I ask
for and the guard said oh you should ask
for Grand Theft Auto so Ali asked for
Grand Theft Auto and he got it and I
guess there's missions that come up on
the screen and he would pause it he
would translate that with the dictionary
and that's how he learned English and so
when I first started uh talking with Ali
there was some language skills that we
had to remedy before
you're very very specific vocabulary
that maybe not be always great to use
so yeah and so I think for me it was it
was interesting to see the juxtaposition
between one Administration the other and
how it affected these men
but also again they're shut off from the
world so they're no Facebook no internet
no nothing no social media no
smartphones
um
well they did pick it up quite quite
quickly once they got out it's it's it
was a pretty fast intake but I think you
know it it's things that we just don't
think about right and so part of the
that year-long course is yes it's
de-radicalizing these men but it's also
treating them for PTSD from Guantanamo
it's also trying to give them life
skills so when they leave the center
they can get a job find a wife have a
family because statistically according
to according to the instructions of the
centers they're way less likely to get
involved with these groups again if
they're married and have a kid and you
know families to take care of
think
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably around near like
the sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time
do you really imagine you're gonna get
Douglas Murray near the frozen food
aisle if you want to ask our incredible
guest questions and have access to
phenomenal behind the scenes content
then you have to be on our locals that's
right for only seven dollars a month you
get incredible extra content behind the
scenes footage giveaways and also the
chance to be part of an incredible
Community where you can meet and hang
out with like-minded people you get
access to our American Vlogs as we
travel across the country interviewing
Our Heroes an extra 20 minutes of our
viral Sam Harris episode as he discusses
his approach to covert we're also going
to start doing giveaways of exclusive
trigonometry merchandise like this a
poster from our Edinburgh show signed by
both of us and also a House of Lords
Teddy which you can only get in the
House of Lords signed by the one and
only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
and you made this film it took three
years it's wonderful it's beautiful I
really enjoyed it I actually watched it
on a phone because I was gone I know I
know blush for me
I know I shouldn't have told you that
because I was going from Geek to Gig and
doing whatever else but the moment I
watched it it hooked me in it I thought
it was brilliant and normally when you
watch something on a phone you
you know it's it's not the way it's
meant to be consumed but it was
incredible and it's a very powerful
piece of work so you made this film and
it's genuinely brilliant then what
happens because the story takes another
turn now yeah so it took actually longer
than three years to make it was a year
full year just to get access three years
of filming two years of editing and I
guess if you want to count the last
years of being blacklisted so so
the time but yeah um
you're saying what happened
so so the story of the film because
there's a story of making the film yeah
but then there's the story of the film
itself
yeah so the film uh I don't know how
familiar you guys are with Sundance but
it's like the it's the holy grail for
independent film fest yeah
exactly and so for documentaries in
particular it's the premier Festival so
for example if you get a film into
Sundance most likely that film is going
to be part of the it film of that year
and so there's a handful of films that
just are everywhere and usually the one
those are the ones that Premiere at
Sundowns for example
when we got into Sundance
um the pr guy that we were working with
he's like I've watched every single film
at Sundance this year because everyone
wanted him to rep his film and he said
this film this film is the only one that
like stuck with me I'm like still
thinking about it he's like this is
going to be the front runner for the
Oscars this is this is gonna be the film
of the year and so it's that kind of
platform that Sundance allows you to
have and so typically normally it will
launch a film and the issues brought up
in the film the stories are brought up
is something that we're going to be
talking about for that entire year and
in doing so it also launches the career
of people who made the film be it the
director the producer the animators on
this film and it kind of just levels up
your your playing field in terms of your
your career but
the opposite happened
unfortunately and why
uh that is a good question I noticed I
want to know the exact answer
um I I would say that in the beginning I
didn't quite understand it but like I
said there's three types of people in
the world
and I'm the third when you someone hits
you I asked why so I did a huge Deep
dive into this and
um read a lot of books uh did a lot of
investigative journalism trying to
figure out what was what was the cause
what was the epicenter how this all come
about because what you have to
understand is while you're making a film
at least while I'm making a film while
I'm editing it I don't just edit it by
myself I do test screening so we'll have
audiences come in various audiences so
for example we screened this for Muslims
yemenis Garza Guantanamo uh
conservatives liberals Progressive all
across the board old young everything
and you do that to make sure one the
film that you're making is making sense
but two especially for this film am I
missing something uh because I knew that
this film was going to get attacked I
didn't think it was going to be from the
left though I was pretty sure it was
going to be from the right
um and so in all those feedback sessions
we kind of over time made this film
quite nuanced quite complex and and for
lack of a better term like try to make
it as bomb proof I.E like do our due
diligence fact checking all this stuff
as possible
um and so when we got in the Sundance we
were just elated and then they announced
the lineup and so they announced lineup
almost about two months a little bit
less than two months before you actually
start the festival so they announced on
the 9th of December and the film
premiered on the 22nd of January
and the day after they announced the
film before anyone had seen it the films
just started to get attacked online bye
uh initially we didn't know who the
people were and initially this is what I
thought to be completely honest
I think most people would have said that
oh this person's attacking my film they
haven't seen it seen it screw them
that was not my initial response uh
having lived in the Middle East for a
very long time having had a lot of
really close friends and people that
consider family who are Muslims in the
U.S
I was well aware of the last 20 years in
the United States being a Muslim in the
U.S has been a lot harder after 9 11 on
a plethora of levels
for example someone that I consider my
sister
when she moved from here from the Middle
East she wears the hijab and she was
like three steps out of the uh airport
and someone spit her face and told her
to go back to where she came from
and this is one incident but over 20
years those things add up and so it can
be quite uh traumatizing for someone
over a long period of time and so what I
initially thought was
okay here's a population of people who
have seen all these negative tropes be
portrayed in the media of Muslims that
reinforces negative stereotypes that's
is sensationalistic
um and they probably think that this
film is like every other film that's
been made about terrorism
but if it were to be fair there's no way
Sundance would have programmed it
um so I thought this was just a big
misunderstanding and I thought once I
see the film like they'll realize that
this is very very different from what
people are perceiving it to be and so I
I reached out via Sundance because they
were contacting Sundance directly or
like requiring that they like you know
pull the film and do us other stuff
um and so Sundance was getting really
worried and they were starting to waver
or they seemed like they were starting
to waver and so I offered through
Sundance and through a different
organization because at that time I
didn't know these people were to come
and Screen the film before Sundance
and according to someone at the festival
they said in the history of this of
Sundance no one's ever offered to show
their film to the group of people
attacking it before it actually
premieres but that's how certain I was
that this was a misunderstanding
and then they got back to us and they
said we don't want to because I offered
to fly down to LA with me and my
executive producer Muhammad who's yemeni
and I I said me and my humble fly down
we'll answer any questions you have
we'll show you the film because we're
still editing at that point so if you
actually have some really good notes
we'll probably take them and then you
could we could have a discussion
afterwards
and they got back to us and said we
don't want to talk with Meg you don't
want to talk with Muhammad we don't want
to watch the film we only want to go
through Sundance and we're insulted that
you even asked us to assign an NDA which
we asked everyone to do who watches the
film before the premiere it's pretty
industry standard
and at that point I was like I don't
really know what else I can do because I
can't have a discussion with someone
about a film that they haven't seen
and so
and so uh the the attacks continued
right uh until yeah so for those six
weeks two months whatever it was
um and what I didn't realize was how
strong confirmation bias was
and what I mean by that is for
almost two months
you had people going in chat rooms and
going on messaging boards and on Twitter
and writing letters saying
things about this film
uh have you not seen it like the film is
propaganda for the Saudis it's funded by
the Saudis uh the it's an all-white film
crew and they don't know anything about
the Middle East and and they just lucked
into this or they've been hoodwinked by
the Saudi government to do this thing
again they had not seen it and so once
you see the film and that's something
that's been so frustrating is I've
realized that the best offense against
all these accusations against all these
attacks is the film itself right I agree
yeah
one of the things that we didn't
actually talk about just very briefly
the ending of the film was fascinating
to me because uh up until that point
you're basically looking at the story of
a bunch of people who went to Guantanamo
Bay some of them uh some of them were
hardened terrorists some of them were
there somewhere by accident some of the
go join in blah blah blah and you're
watching them be rehabilitated and as I
said you cover the fact that not all of
them are successfully rehabilitated but
most of them are and you're watching
that price you're going well this is
interesting and then
towards the end of the movie there's a
little Switcheroo because as we talked
about already the guy who founded the
center gets replaced in fact he gets
arrested Muhammad bin Salman takes over
and suddenly this Center isn't doing
what he was doing at all anymore and one
of the most charismatic teachers at the
center
who was there with the big smile on his
face teaching these men how to live life
and whatever when you try to speak to
him
post the transfer of power yeah he's
like a robot and he's refusing to answer
your questions and I I'm very familiar
with this being from Russia where you
have a strong dictator at the top and if
he doesn't want something to happen
everyone else is terrified yeah they'll
just pretend that the thing that they
used to do for 10 years up until right
now was the exact opposite of what
actually happened yeah and so that
authoritarianism really shows too so the
idea that this was a film funded by the
Saudis I mean that is just ridiculous in
anyone has seen it would would get it
but you mentioned left and right and I
can see I suppose why some on the right
would at least instinctively not want to
engage with this right well yeah I mean
again when we were doing the test
screenings most of the criticisms that
we got in the test screens were from
people who were on the right said listen
you need to tell me exactly what these
men have done and you need to make them
confess exactly what they've done and my
response to that was always like like
listen
the US government had these men for a
decade and a half and they have with all
the resources in the world could not
produce enough evidence to be on a shot
of it out to be able to charge and
convict these men
and specifically say what they didn't
did not do and the New York Times also
did a podcast called caliphate I don't
know if you're familiar with it with all
the resources the New York Times they
did this this amazing podcast I won all
these Awards and later they found out
that all of this was false and based on
a lie huge controversy in the journalism
world now the New York Times the US
government with a bazillion more
resources than I have can't do this
then there's no way that I can right so
I chose to when you introduce the men or
when you see them in one shot we have
the dossier and the of what the American
government says they said these are the
things that we are accusing these men of
doing but then for the next 90 minutes
of the film The Men tell their side and
if it's important to you you can make up
your own mind but for me the film wasn't
about the what they did specifically but
the why because the what is done can't
do anything about it now and but I think
for me what was really really
interesting for me is trying to figure
out the why because the why is something
that we can actually work with and move
forward no I I totally get it I was
mainly focusing on what who are the sort
of people that may be critical of it and
as I say I can see why people on the
right yeah may have some reservations
about it even though haven't seen the
film I think those reservations aren't
founded yeah I think people on the right
can watch that movie and enjoy it and
think it's valuable and a great movie
Personally
um but the left why is the left upset
about or people on the left
um so I wouldn't say a people it's a
small group of so the the people who
found out later that we're attacking the
film were two groups one was a group of
six documentary filmmakers who were
Muslim and according to uh people at
Sundance they'd applied to Sundance and
not gotten in
um and
and I think that
for me if you are attacking a film that
you haven't seen
um and you're talking person that you've
never met uh then the problem is not
with me with me or the film what I mean
by that is we talked before about having
um 20 years of kind of really really
really being discriminated against the
United States if you're a Muslim
and so I can understand the knee-jerk
reaction to this film
however I also feel like
in general I think the people attacking
the film hadn't seen it and there was
preconceived notions of what it was and
I think to we live in a world today
where once you plant a flag right it's
very few people have the courage to pick
that up and say I was wrong but also
even they watched the film what is the
criticism of the film
uh so it's kind of changed over time it
doesn't surprise me so initially the
criticism was it was Saudi
propagandified by the Saudis yeah and
people saw the film and realized that's
not true and then it was like okay the
problem with this film it was done by an
all-white film team and they just lucked
into this and they didn't know what they
were doing and then clearly no one did a
background check on me or the team
because our executive producer is Muslim
the co-producer is Muslim assistant
editor is Muslim and we consulted with
two Islamic scholars and a mom for this
film which is one of the reasons why
it's such a nuanced like really deep
dive into this world I don't think that
could have been done without that input
what I'm trying to get at is why are
people refusing to show your film
there's a reason to show the film as
fear
um so for example
when the attacks started on the film and
um on me again
it reminded me of a so when I was a
firefighter I went on this call
and this guy's kid had been seriously
hurt
we show up and you know the mother's
crying the kids bleeding out but the
father is rightly pissed and he's
yelling at us where the [ __ ] have you
been what [ __ ] took you so long
you're so [ __ ] incompetent rage
rage direct to the people that were
trying to help him
and I remember after we got on the kid
packed up and in the ambulance and they
were at earshot one of the other
firefighters said to me
that guy's lucky I didn't [ __ ] deck
him
and our captain turned around and said
something that I will never forget it's
like listen
but you have to understand about the job
that you do is you're meeting people at
the most traumatic moment of their lives
and everyone responds differently to
trauma
some people cry some people laugh and
some people lash out in anger and this
is how this guy was processing his
trauma
and so
that always stuck with me and so when
the initial attacks on the film happened
I thought that's what it was right so
again these people haven't seen the film
they have never met me
but the attacks in the film were so
ferocious I was like okay I remember my
captain saying even though this man is
angry at you it's not about you because
he's never met you and that was what I
was feeling at the time
but later what I found out or what I
came to kind of discover is that there's
a group of people in in the documentary
world that believe that
if you are not from a community you
should not be allowed to this is not a
new story to us you basically if you're
if you're not black you can't make jokes
about black people if you're not this
you can't make movies about that that's
it's the identity the infiltration of
identity into everything we do now right
and and that's what you find yourself on
yeah that was that was quite a bit part
of it I think a lot of it also is with
Sundance the stakes are so high they
take few films and so when one of the
few films that they programmed was
directed by a white non-muslim and that
was something that was a bit of pure
pill for some people to swallow and
called Sundance out on that quite
ferociously on on on Twitter
and after a while the pressure mounted
to such a
Apex that Sundance
um eventually apologized for programming
the film not once but twice and in doing
so they sent a signal to the rest of the
film industry that there was something
innately wrong with this film because to
my knowledge I don't think Sundance has
ever apologized for any film that
they've programmed and they've done a
lot of really [ __ ]
edgy films that were very challenging
and pissed off a lot of people
um
but
I apologize for this film it set a
signal and when that happened South by
Southwest pulled the film
uh San Francisco documentary film
festival pulled the film and also took
back an award that they had given us the
Vanguard award and it just kind of
um had a knock-on effect from there and
it basically the film was blacklisted
and it wasn't until almost a year later
uh when a very Intrepid and
well-respected journalist investigative
journalist Pulitzer prize-winning
investigative journalist did a I think a
four-month deep dive into this uh for
the New York Times and it wound up on
the front page of the Sunday Times and
that was the first time that people
actually said hey maybe maybe we should
take a second look at that what's really
interesting though is actually he wasn't
the first person to write about it but
he was the first time people took it
seriously before right after Sundance
um the lead film critic and and TV
critic at the LA Times is Muslim
Lorraine Ellie brilliant woman and she
watched the film and she wrote this
whole piece about like listen I'm a
Muslim I love this film and here's all
the reasons why we should not be
canceling this film this is a film
that's going to do more good than harm
and she was then attacked online by this
group
and then another Muslim who's a very
well respected investigative journalist
uh Zay Jelani I think is his last name I
think I'm pronouncing that right
probably not he did a piece I think the
actual title of it was Jihad rehab is
about compassion not bigotry so he had
two very well respected Muslim
journalists and film critics defending
the film but even with that that you're
a white woman though so
that's how it works it is how it works
make what was the official line that you
were given as to why Sundown structure
film as to why South by Southwest San
Francisco yeah all incredibly
prestigious film festivals for people
not aware South by Southwest Sundance I
mean they're the very Apex of
documentary filmmaking what was the
official line that you were giving as to
why your film was no longer being
screened well the the so so
it but then they apologized for it which
was was basically like once you do that
they apologize for programming and show
it to people and the quote was because
showing the film hurt the Muslim
Community
is what the the reason they gave for
apologizing but the problem is that just
wasn't true and they knew it wasn't true
because while all the attacks were
happening Sundance before the film
Premiere was starting to waver and I
asked someone that I really trusted I'm
not I don't know what to do I think sun
is actually going to pull this film
before it ever premieres and he said
like well there's a lot of people who
are organized who haven't seen the film
for the Muslim Community the filmmakers
who are trying to pull it you know loads
of Muslims who've seen the film who've
worked on the film who love this film
have them write letters to Sundance ask
them on to like tell Sundance why this
is important to them and they did and so
Sundance knew that there was a large
portion of the Muslim Community who
really supported this film but because
of these six filmmakers were so well
organized and because Twitter is uh you
can go on Twitter and tweet 100 times a
day and it seems like the whole world
hates you but it's actually only half a
dozen people and so the magic of social
media is you can amplify a voice to a
disproportionate level where it feels
like a cacophony but it's actually just
a whisper
and what effect do you think that's
going to have on documentary films as a
genre because to me the best documentary
films are films like yours where you go
and tackle a subject that is taboo that
we do that all these types of narratives
are spread about this particular issue
and then you debunk them yeah so what
message does that send to the entire
industry
honestly uh this is something that I've
thought about for a while now because I
think initially you're always like what
about my film what about my team uh what
about all the people who worked on this
but then after a while when you sit with
it you start thinking a little bit
bigger
and for me one of the reasons why I got
into independent documentary filmmaking
is because there's no [ __ ] way this
film would ever have been made by a
broadcaster Studio
and what I love about the independent
space it is allows you to dive into
these subjects in a way that does
challenge people's perspective that does
push the boundaries that will ruffle
feathers
and you know the ultimate platform for
that independent space for that
independent voice is or it used to be
Sundance
and so in terms of the whole freedom of
expression movement Freedom the Arts
Movement I naively thought like yes
there's all these other places that are
like you know clamping down but we're
independent filmmakers we're
Independents whole world the whole
reason we do this is because we're not
bound by advertisers or or you know
shareholders
and what I realized was
that freedom of expression and freedom
in the Arts is not a hill to die on it
is the hill
it is the hill
and for me early on when a lot of people
who I was working with and who was
advising me said just apologize just
apologize I asked you know what am I
apologizing for like what did I do wrong
if there's something in the film that is
factually inaccurate and we [ __ ] up
yes I will when you do something wrong
you should apologize but for me
apologize apologizing or apologies are
not performative like if I [ __ ] you over
I'm going to pull you aside face to face
and genuinely say like you deserved it
yeah no I mean I think that like like
for me
you know I make mistakes all the time of
course when you do something wrong you
should apologize yeah of course I get it
but you didn't do anything but when you
don't and the thing is I think what what
you don't realize is is it wasn't just
me right away saying I didn't do
anything wrong I literally took a step
back when we got all these attacks right
after Sundance
I did some test screenings because I
thought [ __ ] when someone comes at you
that hard my instinct was did I miss
something
so we had three test screens right after
Sundance the first one was a group of
people that were mixed in terms of like
you had so I asked them I said raise
your hand if you've never heard about
this film before half the people raised
their hand okay raise your hand if
you've gone on Twitter you know what the
controversy read some of these op-eds
the other half raised their hand they
watched the film I swear to God down the
line everyone that came in the film cold
loved the film
everything that went on Twitter first
had all these issues with it I was like
okay this is really interesting what's
the you know they filled all these like
feedback forms I said what's the biggest
issue of the film
this woman raised her hand and she said
clearly these men didn't want to be
filmed and they were uncomfortable with
you and they were scared for the life
and again we screened the film 30 times
before that's how they come across and
we never had that feedback yeah and
that's how they come across it's not
true yes but but but but they saw this
somehow so I'm like let me I just want
to finish this yeah so so I asked her I
was like what in the film specifically
gave you that impression she said what
was clear as day in that scene where
naughter goes on furlough where his
cousin says you know we took two
billions from you but you took two
countries from us the whole entire time
you're talking to his cousin
naughter's not even looking at you he's
not even talking to you he's just
looking straight ahead so clearly he
doesn't want to be filmed and clearly he
doesn't want you to be filming him
because he's won't even look at you I
said okay
uh would it change your mind at all to
know that when you're making a
documentary film if there's a TV or
radio on the background you have to mute
it otherwise you can't cut the footage
together and that particular time
knotter who's a huge soccer fan his
favorite team was playing on the TV and
I'm filming this way and the TV is
behind me so the reason he's staring
straight ahead and not engaged because
it's a tight game he can give two shits
about my conversation about politics he
wants to know if emptyhad's going to win
and what I mean by that is that
experience of that test screening made
me realize how strong confirmation bias
can be I.E if I saw someone you know uh
how do you say your first name again my
brain's party no I want you to [ __ ] it
up so I can get back at you it's
Constantine Constantine right
constantinex Constantine Constantine
Constantine if I said Constantine was a
secret Nazi you're like no I've known
him from yours he's fine he's like a
good guy I mean you wouldn't be the
first person to say that even though I'm
Jewish but like a lot of people like
said this enough times about you I'd be
like hmm and then I go to your house and
I see you have a guidebook for Germany I
was like [ __ ] that that confirms it I've
heard all these things why would he have
a god proof in Germany and it's just
that that confirmation bias is so strong
so the next screening we did I was like
okay I want to do a screen where you
want to find a group of people they were
going to be pissed off about this film
it would be them so young politically
active so I went to the yemeni Student
Union
and we screen the film cold I didn't
tell them the title I didn't tell them
anything about it they loved it one guy
didn't one guy said he we were too soft
from the Saudis and he wanted us to do
in the whole entire history of the
Middle East and how all the bad things
Saudi Arabia did I said maybe that's a
different film
um and then
we did another test screening we found
the same thing
so once I did three test screenings and
we had the same kind of positive
reaction we did before Sundance I then
sent it to experts like Lawrence Wright
who also watched the film people who are
really experts in this field and they
all got back so This film's brilliant
and so once I knew that once I knew for
Beyond a shot of a doubt that I didn't
miss something that's when I was like
I'm not [ __ ] apologizing for this
[ __ ] because there's nothing wrong with
this film well I love what you said in
the entire monologue there and I love
sorry that was like I didn't use the
word monologue sarcastically I think I
thought what you said was brilliant and
I agree with it completely
um particularly about freedom of
expression and freedom and arts which is
as we talked before we started why we
started our show you know we were two
Comedians and so the question it's a
leading question but I I'm curious to
ask you anyway have you considered the
possibility that attacks and criticism
of your film are not well intentioned
I know this is unlikely for you because
you always want to understand the other
people but understanding other people
doesn't necessarily mean giving them an
undue benefit of the doubt
uh here's the thing
when I told you this I thought that in
the beginning but since then I've done
quite a lot of research I was holding
that belief until March mid-march when
someone sent me a video
um so like I said we'd reached out to
this group and we didn't know they were
at first but after Sundance we did and
so my producer actually knew when the
leaders of this group and he emailed her
several times asking to meet her face to
face and to have a human like
conversation about their concerns with
this film
because all this stuff that they've been
accusing this of could be answered if
they either watch the film or talk to me
about how the film was made
I think he reached out to her over a
half dozen times every time she said I
don't want to talk to you like I'm not
going to help rehab this film uh it's
not it's now it's even bigger than your
film it's not about your film anymore
it's about the movement and so
I was we were trying to reach out to him
and I thought this was all in good faith
then mid-march comes around the same
person goes on a panel discussion
about my film so a bunch of people got
together and decided they needed to have
a panel discussion about how horrible my
phone was and during the panel
discussion she says we have all these
questions and the filmmakers aren't
talking to us they won't answer any of
our questions they won't speak to us so
clearly they're guilty of everything
that we're accusing them of
now once I saw that
my response was you're trying to tell me
that my ethics are
in question where you're supposed to be
a truth teller a journalist a
documentary filmmaker and you're [ __ ]
straight up line and misrepresenting
both by film my team and me right
and so that's when I stopped wait you
were saying being gracious and being
trying to give someone the benefit that
out because I want everyone to do that
for me and so I will give you the
benefit of the doubt because I I would
want someone to do the same sure but
when I see you lying
flat outline
misrepresenting when you attack the
people my team so for example they took
screenshots of our credits and reached
out to all the people in the industry in
our credits and and basically harass
them and threaten them and encourage
them to take their name off the film
um and I had you know team members who
receive calls and who literally were
crying for like an hour and a half
afterwards and so for me there's a
difference between criticizing a film
which is normal or a book like you just
came out with a book there's gonna be
people that read your book and not like
it they're going to go on Twitter and be
like in chapter four he says this and I
disagree with that that's fine how did
you know chapter four is literally just
another foreign
but I think like that but that's the
deal that you make right right you you
write a book you make a movie you put it
out in the public space part of that is
you're gonna get criticism however
there's a difference between someone
criticizing your work which a lot of
times actually makes you a better writer
right right makes you a better
Storyteller and then trying to actually
Blacklist your book trying to get it
banned or trying to basically cancel you
and your whole entire career I agree and
I think there's a difference between you
know inquiry
and Inquisition and we are definitely in
Inquisition territory here I agree with
you
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
where do you think
the motivation comes from them
I think there's two different places so
the two different groups that attacked
the film are one was a group of
independent filmmakers and I think
um
there was
people wanting their their work to have
that acknowledgment yeah wanting their
work to have be platformed by Sundance
[Music]
and there was another group that I don't
know if you're familiar with them
actually based in the UK called cage and
I talked to a lot of experts who know
way more about that group than me and
they were described to me is they're an
activist group in the UK that one of the
narratives they push is that everyone in
guantana was completely dis innocent and
never did anything wrong and that's true
for a lot of the people that went to
Guantanamo but that's not true for
everyone and that's not true for the
people in my film
and I specifically cast these people
because from their own mouth
they let you know their level of
involvement
and so basically this expert told me
that this group will attack
any book or movie that challenges that
narrative ferociously with anything from
legal threats to misinformation
campaigns they have a reputation
according to a lot of the experts that I
took has been a very nefarious group and
the really scary thing was is you had a
group like that that was basically
teaming up with a group of progressive
independent filmmakers to attack a film
so it was it made for really strange
bedfellows and there's also the identity
angle too yeah right which is I don't
know how you where you are of this but
there's a big war going on uh in the
sort of cultural space yeah and you
found yourself in the middle of that it
seems like to me well I think I think
yes but I think for me I was I come from
a maybe a different kind of era where
it doesn't matter if you're Russian or
you're British or you're Filipino it's
the work right so you're right just like
us because no but that's how it works
the work should because there's there's
of course because the point is that
we're all different people right but
it's about the thing that you created
not your skin color that's the idea
right the idea for me is is is that you
listen when I first started interviewing
these guys if you go on look on paper we
have [ __ ] nothing in common so for
example the guy that I kind of bonded
with the the quickest was not her uh the
reason for that is when you're a
firefighter you see a lot of horrific
[ __ ]
and you also get to be exposed to some
of the worst things humans can do to one
another on a pretty regular basis
and in order to make it through that job
you have to find a way to process that
stuff and to decompress and how
firefighters release the ones I worked
with chose to do that was through humor
and not like the knock knock joke this
is like politically dark and politically
incorrecting where that in any other
environment would get you fired but it
was just a necessity sometimes to get
through the day
and so I I that kind of humor I've only
seen in one other profession
military folks who've seen combat
outside of that group if you if you
heard those jokes
it would just never land right right
you'd come up with some kind of like
psychopath about joking about trauma and
tragedy
and I never had that kind of interaction
with someone else outside those two kind
of group of friends of mine until I met
naughter
when I first met naughter and we sat
down one-on-one he told me about his
time in Guantanamo and things that were
done to him
but he did this all with a smile on his
face through bouts of uncontrolled
laughter and through really really dark
jokes
and everyone in that room
thought that naughter was some kind of
psychopath or just a flat out line but I
knew better not because I had a crystal
ball not because I was some kind of mind
reader but he told the same kind of
jokes that my firefighter buddies told
me so that meant to me that he was still
processing this trauma he was still like
working through it and so for me he
would tell a joke and I would tell him
back that we found this like immediate
Rapport and connection over our shared
love of inappropriate humor right and
the reason why I tell that story is
because there were people in that room
that on paper had way more in common
with him same sex same religion same
ethnicity
but no one got that level except for me
and that was because we had a shared
life experience of going through this a
really shitty situation and having to
use humor to deal with it and what I
mean by that is
humans are more than the boxes that you
would check on some census
who were made up of so many plethora of
other interesting things that they don't
even have boxes for
and I think because of that I'm able to
have friends who aren't my same race or
sexual identity or whatever and that's
what makes us beautiful as human beings
as we're so we have so many interests
and so many experiences that make us who
we are and I think that sometimes we
forget that and there's a lot of people
that I probably have more in common with
on paper
but would not get the kind of jokes that
naughter did he told me once he was like
Meg
you should go on Guantanamo diet you
lose 40 pounds one month you look really
good and he's talking about you know
hunger strikes he's got he's joking
about hunger strikes and I think that
what you have to realize is that
when you're talking about
connecting with another human being
what you see on a paper is just it
literally is that deep in terms of what
makes us who we are and so when you're
talking about identity yes I think
there's something to be said about a
story being told from an inside
perspective because that's a definitely
different perspective that I couldn't
give
but there's also a lot of ability to an
outside perspective
for example I was a firefighter on 9 11.
I had really strong feelings about this
whole thing
from the get-go and from a very
different perspective
and when 9 11 happened I saw my country
as the victim
but then when I moved to the Middle East
so I moved to Yemen and I saw what my
own government was doing in the region
I looked at my country as a perpetrator
so I had like one foot in each Camp so
as I was making this film that was
constantly on my mind and I was thinking
about my firefighter buddies and what we
went through but I was also thinking
about all the yemi friends that I made
and family in Yemen and all the people
that got disappeared or thrown in
Guantanamo or like the random drone
bombings
and I think that those two life
experiences gave me a very unique
perspective not just to make this film
but into this world
yep I don't know if that is a long time
you said that beautifully that's a
brilliant summation of why you made this
film which was so powerful and had such
an impact on the audience who watched it
and particularly on me so what does the
future now hold for you Mega and your
film Yeah so basically we've pretty much
been blacklisted for entire year and
Untouchable uh very fortunate that the
film was talked about and Vindicated on
the cover of the New York Times the
National Review the Atlantic Sam Harris
podcast and the whole reason why we're
here is because right after it appeared
on the cover of the New York Times a
bunch of people reached out and said how
can we help this seems like a huge
Injustice like do you have a GoFundMe
I'm like I don't but maybe I should make
one
um so I made a GoFundMe
um and I think we got like three
thousand dollars uh I think a thousand
of that was probably from my family I
call scrumping together
um and then uh I went on the Sam Harris
podcast
and had a long conversation with him
about the film and and what was
happening to it and he was very generous
and put it up without a paywall so
anyone could kind of listen to it and so
people forward it on it kind of went
viral and the GoFundMe went from 3 000
three quarters of a million and so we
were able to bring the film to theaters
and so right now what we're trying to do
is bring the film to people to be able
for them to see it and make up their own
mind and one of the reasons why we're in
Britain is we had loads of people reach
out from the UK who were Sam Harris
listeners or listened to the podcast and
just were like please we'd love to see
this film
so that was one reason another reason is
we had someone from Bath to reach out
and they were curious and so I sent them
a link and they're like this film was
like bafta worthy like you should bring
it over here and like qualify it for a
bafta maybe the British public will give
you a fair Shake where the Americans
didn't and
um so we came over here and the reason
why we're playing at the Art House
Crouch end in London is to basically for
the bafta qualification and so all this
month until I think December 30th bafta
members are voting for best documentary
best foreign language film Best Director
of these kinds of things I know it's a
long shot
but one of the reasons we're doing this
is
Sundance is such a well-respected entity
by them apologizing for the film made it
radioactive and even though we have all
these other institutions like the New
York Times the Atlantic vindicating the
film unfortunately within the small
Fishbowl that is the film industry the
film industry we're still pretty
Radioactive
and so the only way to kind of undo that
is to have another entity within the
film industry validate the film
and so that's
probably only going to be either the
academy or bafta and I am not holding my
breath for the Academy but I'm hoping I
went into the BBC today to give an
interview and on the on the cover or on
the cover of the side of the building
there was this quote I think it said
something like
um
it was something like
is it George Orwell yeah it was uh if
Liberty is anything it's telling people
what they don't want Italian people
things they don't want to hear and I saw
that as kind of like an omen before I
went into the interview I was like maybe
this maybe this country is different
maybe they care about freedom of
expression Freedom we won't disabuse you
of that but the BBC has long since
abandoned that anyway
um Meg it's a brilliant film uh and I
think the way you talk about these
issues is really important actually
um and I'm really you know I'm so
grateful because on trigonometry we
often talk to people who've had things
canceled I've been denied an opportunity
because they said the wrong thing or
they've got the wrong skin color
whatever but actually I'm just really
grateful that
we've encountered your film that
otherwise we probably wouldn't have seen
as a result of everything that's
happening so wish you all the best maybe
at some point the film can be available
online for people to pan yeah so my hope
is
um we bring the film to the kind of game
plan right now is try to try to get it
get a bath before at least a nomination
some kind of validation within the film
industry and if from that hopefully that
emboldens some distributors or buyers or
streamers or broadcasters to pick it up
uh hint hint HBO Netflix
um but uh it's worthy of it yeah yeah I
think that but also I've talked to a lot
of people who've done self-distribution
and my goal for the film is to have as
many people watched as possible because
I do think that so many people who've
seen the film in London have had such a
huge positive impact from watching the
film and I think that it's a disservice
that more people can't see it and so
when I was talking to my friend who does
self-distribution he said listen you're
never going to get the audience size
putting on like some random website with
a paywall behind it that you will if it
goes on Netflix or HBO or something like
that so the the goal now is to try to
get some kind of validation within the
film world to be able to give
those buyers maybe a little bit of
Bravery to be able to pick the film up
if that does not happen Plan B is to
self-distribute online so take the film
Out show it to all these different kind
of people in different places around the
world build an audience of people who've
really seen the film so that way when
the film does go up a line eventually
what happened at Sundance won't happen
again you won't have a bunch of people
just telling you what the film's about
no one's seen it you'd have people that
have seen the film and can defend it
when these lies kind of come up again
which they will and I think for me
because there's just me and staff just
the two of us who don't have a huge team
that takes time so right now we're
working to try to find a way to get it
up online which takes like a couple
months unfortunately but it's a long
process it's around three months to get
something up online like this well if
you do end up going in that
self-distribution direction we'd love to
help in any way yeah that would be
awesome of course of course I really
think more people should see it and I
also think people who are nuanced and
are sensible about these things as you
are
you know this is the problem with the
world that we live in at the moment it
is the sensible people it is the people
who are balanced it is the people who
are in the center that are most
vulnerable uh if you if you made a film
talking about how Muslims are all
terrorists there would be a large
audience for that and the fact that
people on the left tried to cancel you
would only help you promote the film and
if you'd made a film about how all
terrorists are actually innocent there'd
be a large audience on the other side of
the political spectrum and the fact that
the right was attacking it would help
you but because you actually have taken
a sensible and reasonable and balanced
position that's why you're left without
a big tribe on your team and that's why
it's become as hard and to me that's the
real tragedy of the cultural moment that
we're in is people like you who are
who are prevented from making things
that actually matter and are actually
good and in that kind of fact
unfortunately has been even worse than
that so what I mean by that is so when
Sundance apologized for the film there
was another film at Sundance the same
year as me called the Exiles and a
different group then started to go after
that group and on Twitter they cited
their reason for them going after the
Exiles was that they cited the success
that the group had come after me and
garnish the Sundance apology and so that
inspired other people to try to take out
other films the knock-on effect being at
the end of the day if you take it to
this natural ending then film festivals
and programmers or owning their programs
safe films which then does a disservice
to the populace that don't get exposed
to these other stories and one thing
that's been extremely alarming for me is
I spent over a half day decade uh
interviewing men who a lot of them
ascribe to a certain ideology right
you're either this type of specific
salafi Muslim either believe these
specific things and act this specific
way
and if you deviate just a little bit
then you're not a real Muslim then
you're an Infidel and you can be
targeted
I then come back to my home country and
I see something that's quite alarming
and it's a very similar kind of feel of
an ideology but in a different iteration
for example you're either this type of
progressive liberal you have to believe
these specific things of the day
but if you deviate just a little bit
then you're not a real liberal you're
not a real Progressive you're sexist
you're homophobic you're racist and you
can be targeted
and for me I've been in a world where
that goes to its natural
fruition and it's scary
and so seeing that kind of ideology and
I do mean the word ideology because
there are people who I know personally
who I considered friends
who
didn't watch the film
but then decided to go online and just
bad mouth it in me because they believed
that that was the right thing to do be
it virtue signaling or be it they
thought it was it was a righteous cause
and what I mean by that is the reason
why I don't think these people are evil
or these people are mean these people or
bad people it's just what you have to
understand about the documentary
Community it's made up of a lot of
people who really want to do good in the
world who really want to change the
world to be a better place
the only downside of that is in that
environment it's also extremely easy to
weaponize empathy
and so if you're trying to be supportive
of a minority group and someone tells
you that this film is hurtful you
believe that minority group and you want
to help Champion their cause but the
problem is when you're a journalist and
you're a truth teller in your
documentary filmmaker
before you jump on any bag wagon your
whole job is to do your due diligence so
if you can't even watch a two-hour film
before chiming in if that's too much
energy for you to do then you are not a
journalist you are an activist that
writes
you are not a documentarian you're an
activist with a camera and so for me I
do draw the line between being a
journalist being a documentarian and
being an activist and I think that those
lines have been gotten blurred lately
and unfortunately it's had a very
negative knock and effect both in
journalism and in filmmaking and so for
me what I hope is as if I'm able to turn
this around
if I'm able to get the fem out there in
a big way in a successful way
then hopefully that will send a message
to the industry say hey before we bend
the knee next time maybe we don't want
to have egg on our face and maybe if we
program a film we stick by it maybe we
would decide to be an EP on a film we
Champion it
because at the end of the day I think
that what's really scary to me
is that if you go back
30 years
we have salmon Rushdie his book
people I think they're translators for
his book were murdered
bookstore still chose to put it on the
bookshelf at a principal and sell it
fast forward 30 years
you have a huge institution like
Sundance
or a
multi-millionaire many times over like
Abigail Disney
and a few tweets and well written
letters and a campaign
causes them to capitulate
and these are supposed to be the
institutions and the industry leaders
they're supposed to safeguard against
that and if those are no longer working
because at the end of the day you're
always going to have people attack your
work that's not new but what is new is
these institutions and and the the
leaderships in these industries aren't
leading
and what I mean by that is the fire
service when you're the captain you have
more responsibility than a firefighter
you take the hit you protect your crew
I was a filmmaker that was accepted into
Sundance
and instead of sundancing protecting the
filmmaker that they programmed they
threw that filmmaker under the bus and
that film and everyone involved in it
and to me that's not leadership and if
you're not leading in the industry then
you're you're basically devaluing the
value that you say you add
and at the end of the day I think
someone once told me the same like
so the only thing more dangerous
than a person
with
Limitless resources and more money than
God is someone who has nothing else to
lose
at this point we got enough to lose
it's a fantastic thank you so much for
coming on the show Meg it's been an
absolute pleasure if people want to find
you online if they want to find out more
about you where is the best place to do
that yeah so we have a GoFundMe page and
we put updates all the time so if you go
to GoFundMe just search Jihad rehab or
or uh makes maker GoFundMe
um we have a website jihadrehab.com
where we put a bunch of screenings and
all those dates as well and they can
follow me on Twitter at m-e-i-g-h-o-n
um or makes maker on Twitter I think
that I think you can search for that I'm
kind of like not really a Twitter expert
I [ __ ] it up a couple times I'm still
trying to learn about it social media
expert at all yeah and then I think you
know if people have any leads in terms
of like if there's a theater near you or
a film festival that you think would be
brave enough or if you are in the
industry or you are a bafta member oh
that's one thing I should say
um for people in the in the UK who are
bafta members you can watch it so it's
on online right now but only for bafta
members and only for Academy voters they
have this very like
huge security protected streaming things
that are available to those members and
they can watch the film and then make up
your own their own mind and that would
be really helpful for more people as
many people to see this film as possible
well we wish you all the best and like I
said if there's anything we can do for
you in the future we'd be very happy to
do that uh with that we've got one final
question for you which is the same as
always what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
I think one thing that I've been kind of
talking about lately
um and really appreciating is the power
of I don't know
what I mean by that is I've had a lot of
discussions with people lately about a
plethora of things and there seems to be
a certitude about things that I've I
know that they don't know a lot about
and what I mean by that is the other day
I was with some friends and I gave them
a hypothetical scenario
I said what would you say if I told you
someone at a major newspaper
tweeted a sexist joke what should happen
to that person
that's a very limited amount of
information
and so I went around the table and I
asked my friends none of my friends
asked for more information they all had
their you know judged during sentence
one was he should be fired another one
was he should be suspended without pay
another one he should be demoted I said
okay what about if
I told you that this journalist was in
the business for 30 years multiple
Pulitzer prizes multiple
Awards and like Woodward and Bernstein
level
and what if I told you that the whole
Twitter thing that he was doing was
literally just mandated a month ago
where his paper said you must tweet at
least twice a week something in order in
order to like meet your minimum
requirement
what if I also told you it told you that
that tweet was sent at two in the
morning on a Friday night
for someone who was you know in his late
60s
probably out the bar drinking what if I
told you he thought he was sending a
private message to a friend on Twitter
and not posting it publicly does that
change how you would punish this person
and of course they all went around and
changed their answer
and then what I realized is
when you give people facts
without context
it's not truth it's propaganda
and so what I really want people to
really kind of drill down on is context
because context is everything and a lot
of times we see videos online that are
10 20 seconds long and we come in and we
judge right away but what we're missing
is the context because context will tell
you more what you need to know and
without that I would employ people to
just take a Beat because having been uh
gotten a lot of hate because there was
no context
I think that it's imperative that people
approach situations with inquiry rather
than Inquisition and with curiosity
rather than judgment
and I would also import people to be
not just kind to one another but give
people the benefit of the doubt we're
all trying to do the best that we can
and none of us are inherently evil
people we all think we're doing the
right thing
so I think the one thing that I would
say is I think people need to seek out
context a lot more than we are
I like you Meg I think it fit very well
in like the late 1990s that's your era
yeah because that world I'm afraid I
wish you were here but it ain't yeah uh
but you're right of course you're right
uh and that there's a great uh that's a
great note to finish on we'll ask you a
couple of questions for our locals uh
Meg smaker that's us thank you very much
brilliantly pleasure
so I went to go interview the head of
the FBI thinking he was going to say
this is some kind of dog a pony show
this is like just a PR stunt
he said and I was really surprised he
said that he said we [ __ ] love this
program and we wish we could do
something like this in the states and I
was like why can't we two reasons he
said one
[Music]